meanwhile chichi gonzalez is the man who
will toss
for the rockies
ground up the middle to mcmahon he flips
it to treyarch at first and chichi works
out of it
reds are really hoping for a strong
start from luis castillo tonight connor
joe is the hitter still waiting for a
pitch as
castillo worries about tapia
this ball is driven in the gap
it's getting away it's gonna be off the
wall it kicks off
tommy's gonna score pretty easily connor
joe with the double inside out swing
good start for the rocks
ryan takes over as the base runner at
first with yesterday's second game hero
josh fuentes at the plate
3-2 mcmahon will be moving his boss
tripping out towards left field
get out of here
back-to-back days for josh fuentes a
two-run shot
and the rockies have a three nothing
lead
i gave a lot of credit yesterday in the
post game to dave magden just tell him
to go out there see the ball relax
but you know what after you have had
results that's what you get
all two
suarez was maybe 50 feet away from home
plate when that ball was delivered
i don't know what they're talking about
right now
is there a
i'm not sure but the umpires are going
to get together
ron gideon was
talking to first base umpire bruce
dreckman
and then immediately dreckman went in
and signaled the rest of the umpires to
come together for a conference
there was a block but here comes the
call
what do we got we still got
joe tell us what's going on
[Music]
it's gonna it's gonna stay stay the same
chopper down the third baseline is it
going to stay fair
yes it is
i think mark grabs them in the grounds
crew because they added a little more
paint to the one side so the ball didn't
go foul
face it down the left field line
goss is going to third
the throw behind
treyo slides in dives into the back side
he's safe
that was a hustled double by alex and i
like what daza did he force the hand of
jesse winker and left field connor joe
with the opportunity and a big one
rockies up three nothing bases loaded
two outs in the fourth
little soft floater over the head of the
second baseman it's going to drop
dazzy scores treyo scores
tapia goes to third
and the ball hasn't been hit
particularly hard this inning but it's
been hit the right spot connor joe might
be one of my new favorite players
tapia gets over to third charlie
blackman to take his turn
the pitch and that one's ripped off the
glove of mustaches the ball goes down
the right field line tapia is in over to
third joe
rockies get another run on the sharp
single by charlie blackman and it's six
to nothing already three runs in this
inning for the rockies and they're not
done yet
runners will be off joe from third with
a big lead down the line suarez way off
the bag there goes blackman the pitch is
driven to center field that'll fall
for a base hit in to come to score
connor joe rbi single for ryan mcmahon
and the rockies keep adding on it is
seven to nothing two on now for josh
fuentes the ninth man to bat what is a
four run fourth for the rockies
four straight have reached after two men
were out in this pitch to fuentes is hit
to center field akayama coming on and
that'll drop for a base hit blackman
into score mcmahon to third and the
rockies do it again
rbi single for fuentes makes it eight to
nothing
topia one for two on the night
eight nothing rockies two outs here in
the fifth bouncing ball towards short
charging farmer will have to hurry and
the high throw
ends up
going out of play and
trejo scores
2-2 is cued fair inside the third
baseline
for ryan mcmahon winker up with the ball
fires it into second but mack has
a double
josh who has a two run homer and an rbi
single on the night
check on mcmahon at second
2-2 is hit into center field that's
going to drop for another blue pit
they'll send mcmahon home throw coming
to the plate is not in time
a four rbi night on three hits
chichi gonzalez back in the clubhouse
now helping himself to some cafeto's
ground ball right between short and
third into left field for a base hit
jonathan india has his first hit of the
night
tyler stevenson looks like he's the
right-handed hitter coming up
the pitch and he swings hits this one
high in the air and deep right center
field way back way gone pinch hit two
run home run tyler stevenson
10-2 rockies
home run by stevenson
hard ground ball through
akiyama rips through second
daza from right throws to second
[Music]
nick castiano's aboard for a third time
first and third blandino came on for
mustaches
that is throw hakiyama scores castiano
slows at second daza tosses in
scoring hit by alex blandino a three
spot in the eighth barn hard over three
and barnard spanks that into left field
castiano's given the wave tapia from
left with a big lead don't even take the
chance a lob to third base castellano
scores
barnhart the run scoring hit a four run
eight the only
red in the lineup
that had not hit in the inning now
stands in kyle farmer
that's a rip into center field
landino scores
barnhart to third
five runs in the eighth as the reds have
batted around and cut their deficit in
half david bell's team has mended first
and third two outs jonathan india to
stand in
high fly deep right from india
gone
jonathan india
booms a three-run homer it is an
eight-run eighth inning and the reds
have roared back from down ten to within
two
in eight colorado
dasa two hits and a walk on a two for
three night and he drives it to right
field this has a chance off the top of
the wall
nunez to third it's a double wild throw
and it gets away
nunez scores
it's 11-8
rockies lead back to three
allen a double tonight he sends it in
the air to right field castillanos near
the line will make the catch dazzett
tags heads to the plate he's in there on
the slide
12-8 rockies
he drives it towards left field going
back winker to the wall it is out of
here
touch him all time for garrett hampson
number four for the hamptonator
it's 13 eight
rockies
to second and the pitch and it's line to
left rymel tapia is there and that's the
game final score in game one
rocky's 13. cincinnati eight